Republicans senator Cory Gardner of
Colorado says the president made the
right decision he's chairman of the
Foreign Relations Subcommittee on East
Asia the Pacific and international
cybersecurity policy senator Gardner is
with us from Denver good morning senator
let's start with why this deal fell
apart you say it was the right thing for
the president to do why was it the right
thing for the president to do well I
think we've known all along that if
there was any sense that Kim jong-un was
not committed to denuclearization this
meeting wouldn't occur and in the weeks
leading up to the summit meetings were
canceled that we had the State
Department officials meeting in
Singapore with North Korean officials
those meetings were canceled phone calls
were not returned they canceled meetings
with the South Koreans and so I I think
it's appropriate to make sure that when
we get to this summit it's not about
games it's not about propaganda
it's about denuclearization isn't this
why these summits though are worked out
beforehand at a lower level so that you
don't have national prestige at stake
between the leaders this early in the
negotiating process because obviously
North Korea is not going to say yeah
we'll give up the entire program right
off the bat well I think what's happened
is that that those planning efforts were
being made if you look at the meeting
that was going to be held in Singapore
that was all leading up to the summit in
Singapore and so phone calls that
weren't returned they were going to be
planning efforts for Singapore I think
what happened over the past couple of
weeks kim jeong-hoon either has started
to lack the support within his closest
confidants the old guard perhaps putting
pressure on him as saying this isn't the
way your father did things you can't do
this or maybe even the meeting with
President Xi as has been talked about
publicly had changed the results a
little bit of Kim Jong Un's attitude as
it related to the summit did China try
to bring him in a little closer and
saying hey we're nervous about making a
deal with the Americans and so we'll
relax the sanctions those are all
questions that we have to have answers
for that we have to continue our maximum
pressure doctrine but I hope that we can
get back to a position where we do
indeed have a deal on denuclearization
sooner I want to talk about just how
damaging this may be to the u.s.
position as you referred to there was a
White House deputy chief of staff
waiting in Singapore for North Korean
officials and was stood up by the North
Koreans
but now the North Koreans have gotten
public recognition they may get an
easing of sanctions they can continue
with their nuclear program
doesn't this just strengthen China in
the end well to be clear there we know
easing of sanctions in fact the
commitment that I received yesterday
from the Secretary of State I was at the
White House meeting with national
security adviser at Bolton
we will double down on our sanctions in
fact Congress is prepared to pass
additional sanctions legislation that
I've put in place called the lead act
it's already out of the Foreign
Relations Committee just needs to move
through the full Senate now in the house
we can double down on these sanctions to
further isolate North Korea economically
and diplomatically to continue to
ratchet up our pressure but I don't
think this is any kind of a win for
North Korea in fact this fits a pattern
of misbehavior his promises by his
family have been broken over the decades
many times and so this isn't anything
new what we see is an internal challenge
and struggle between kim jeong-hoon a
challenge between this peacemaker to
bring his Hermit Kingdom out of the
darkness and this challenge the struggle
between the propagandist a pattern of
behavior by North Korea that gets global
attention and then they break the
promise and in this instance it looks
like the propagandist won over in that
internal debate all right senator
Gardner thank you so much for joining us
we appreciate it